round it should still boom displace okay
it should still displace okay so it
should go into his body so I had to
ground back boom
boom boom boom think about
your this is more angles as opposed to
hip rotation shoulder strength okay it's
more angles boom right up this middle
boom right through this side but you're
you're in
is still on the
ground this time I'm going to take the
jab cross but this one's going to be a a
flicker jab okay so I'm not it goes
through the eyes but I I want something
a little sof you feel but it's the same
thing it's not a wimpy strip my body
boom my body and my ground Vector are in
it okay and then the next one is going
to be a palm heel after you hit the Palm
heel the eyes the fingers go in the eyes
too so they're two one quick eyes pump
Pop Eyes okay same thing ground sorry
okay ground get this angle boom raise
right boom I might be able to get the
inner thigh right boom to take his base
out so and
boom pop
and move his
m